exterior University of Maryland campus
College Park Maryland quenwen PhD
associate professor UMD epidemiology and
biostatistics this particular project
funded by the National Library of
Medicine is producing a new National
Data resource for built environment
characteristics using Google sheet view
images and computer vision models and to
estimate the association between Bill
environment characteristics and health
outcomes on a national level Ming who
AIA ncarb l-e-d-a-p associate professor
Affiliated faculty ncsg and Maryland
Transportation field environment in the
simplest way is just everything human
built it includes the streets all the
buildings all the houses tunuan SCD mcph
associate professor UMD epidemiology and
biostatistics we merged the Google image
data with the patient data so we looked
at coronary artery disease hypertension
and diabetes and then our mouth control
for individual characteristics such as
like race ethnicity Insurance status
English language ability split screen
with three California maps and
individual street views in our pilot
study we merge those indicators with
patient data in Utah it was close to a
million patient records split screen of
three city maps indicating sidewalk data
Healthcare Systems want to know what are
some exposures that their patients
encounter and what are some of the
predictors that can help them better
understand where's The Chronic risk
disease coming from scenes of
recreational park overhead utility wires
in a devastated house we found that like
greenness of streets are visible wires
or the evaporated buildings predicted
prevalence of chronic heart disease and
hypertension diabetes quenwen walks on a
crosswalk in a Suburban neighborhood so
crosswalk and sidewalks are indicators
of walkability so the more walkable
neighborhood is the more it encourages
physical activity we have other
indicators is like Street trees and
Street Greenery which promote which we
found are associated with lower obesity
and better mental health we made a
geoportal where you can select the naked
feature that you're interested in
Washington DC is typed into the search
field of the geoportal you can also zoom
into a location so you can type in
address or a city and it'll naturally
that neighborhood people can interact
with the data it allows for a quick
analyzes flexible boundaries and
publicly available and it's a huge data
source for for the public health
researchers and policy makers doing this
way it can give us first a set of large
data to show us what is the impact of
the building we design and we build
without nlm support we wouldn't have the
protected time that we had over five
years we wouldn't be able to purchase
the images and also purchase the the
Computing software and Hardware to run
the models and also the granite help
support doctoral students and fund their
their entire studies various shots of
suburban neighborhood buildings it takes
a Civic amount of time to walk in
inventory neighborhood features of the
built environment
and so that would not be possible if you
are interested in Newports across the US
and thus we need computer vision and
Google sheet view images to enable the
analyzes at the national level
for the geoportal search for the link in
the description area
for more on this project go to the link
in the description area
NIH nlm Grand blue logo serving
scientists in society